I'll open up chrome dev tools emulator
and look at a mobile view of the web
fundamental site
I'll open chrome navigate to web
fundamentals then open the chrome
developer tools using command ops + J or
ctrl alt J next I'll hit the emulator
button
it's that phone looking icon in the
toolbar great the emulator is ready to
go I can start loading pages and see how
they look but before I do I like to dock
the tools to the right side of the
browser window since most phones are
viewed and portrait docking to the right
side gives me the most amount of
vertical space the other thing I need to
do is pick the device that I want to
emulate chrome has a bunch of predefined
devices that I can choose from it
automatically sets the viewport size the
user-agent string device pixel ratio and
enables touch emulation if you're not
familiar with some of these terms don't
worry we'll cover them as part of this
course now I can see how a page renders
across different devices without ever
leaving Chrome sweet that looks about
how I'd expect it Chrome has several
other things that it can emulate for you
in the emulation panel hit escape to
bring it up why don't you go check out a
few sites with different emulated
devices and see how they behave and
don't forget to check out some of the
other things that you can emulate while
you're there